je les aimais mes chiens dans un sanglot
l'éleveur 30 jusqu'au bout de convaincre
de sa bonne foi il reconnaît avoir perdu
pied après l'avc de son épouse et la
naissance de sa fille mais il nie toute
maltraitance
il maintient avoir continuer à nourrir
ses animaux pas quotidiennement ils
l'avouent mais avec des animaux plus
riche en protéines pour les parties
civiles une dizaine dans ce dossier
l'éleveur était certes en souffrance
mais reste responsable de ses actes
tournées lui des gens il ya des
vétérinaires il ya des associations ya
des sciences vétérinaires comme tout
cela a été mentionné dans le lot 10 ans
je pense que bon même si ce qui a été
dit juste c'est à dire qu'il avait honte
probablement de montrer cela il y avait
d'autres moyens que de se réfugier dans
le silence et de laisser ces animaux à
l'agonie au terme de cinq heures
d'audience un record pour ce type
d'affaires les réquisitions du parquet
tombe six mois avec sursis assortis
d'une mise à l'épreuve avec obligation
de soins interdiction d'exercer le
métier d'éleveur et même de détenir un
animal
la défense avait demandé la relaxe je
trouve que le quantum est assez haut
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a passé sa
vie à s'occuper de ses chiens et qui
aujourd'hui risque d'être condamnée
parce qu'on lui reproche de ne pas
soutenir suffisamment occupés alors
qu'il a tout fait il ne dormait plus il
ne dormait plus qu'une heures par nuit
il ne mangeait plus il s'occupait de ses
bêtes du soir au matin le délibéré est
fixé au 15 novembre
dans cette affaire une vingtaine de
chiens et chats avaient trouvé la mort
et 32 autres avaient été placées
d'urgence par les associations